vous l'attendiez avec impatience inquiet
hâte de voir le congrès 2 place de kelly
et d'agathe ah oui c'est parti pour le
conseil de classe de deux chroniqueuses
de choc d'un côté la blonde platine
kelly tariel à m merci et ben merde et
de l'autre la brune à lunettes
ça va ça va toi qui lis vdev dit c'est
avant tout la djette de l'émission kelly
ne peut toujours pas envoyé de sont
toujours au taquet pour mettre
l'ambiance très amer c'est ça mais kelly
c'est aussi une grande passionnée de
médias le bruyant guillon dans les
z'amours ça vous intéresse je m'emballe
est d'accord ce que ça m'a choqué malek
total est bondé d'aimer ou pas n'importe
comment sera concernée je pars chronique
est à eauze et poivre c'est là pour
l'adar quart place maintenant à l'élève
agathe points forts ses habits très
tranché les femmes sont considérées
comme des objets dans la téléréalité
merci oui elles sont toutes
hypersexualisée ont le vent dans ces
légendes excellente prestation en danse
[Musique]
mais un peu moins en chant en rouge et
noir l'exergue danemark avec elle c'est
qu'elle est persuadée que c'est une
grosse faute sur moi même et elle chante
dans au point faible d'agathe élèves un
peu rebelle avec le professeur et ses
camarades c'est la calade toujours 25
ans abba merci de me donner la parole
série l'enfant et voilà pour le vision
des élèves qui est lié à gap en tout cas
une chose est sûre on aimerait tous les
avoir dans notre classe le conseil de
classe
on va démarrer ce conseil de classe très
fort puisqu'on va démarrer jean-luc un
d'accord tu n'étais pas échauffé je vais
baisser de pomme croquée alors j'ai
commencé par kelly kelly a réussi un
exploit et s'est rendu indispensable en
un an
alors qu'on sait toujours pas ce qu'a
fait dans l'émission c'est fabuleux
parce qu'au début on pensait qu'elle
passait la musique on a compris qu'elle
ne faisait pas d'ongles ayant on sait
pas pourquoi les punis dans son coin
parce que pour être à la table non elle
est bien là bas ben oui mais c'est ça
mais on a besoin qu'il loge de concierge
voix dame pipi je sais pas c'est très
très bizarre je mets une petite coupelle
est bon et c'est vrai que je pensais
qu'elle avait envie de donner son avis
puis serait voulait montrer un magnéto
très souvent a dit bah je m'en fous je
m'en fous un bal est là pour l'adar cas
alors il ya un truc qui est formidable
et qu'elle sait qu'elle est solaire et
les ultras télégénique d'humeur égale
c'est une très bonne camarade donc elle
a réussi à son indispensable vraiment et
je suis sincère quand je dis vite agathe
elle a fait un très bon début d'année
sur la lancée de sa première année je
trouve
et puis après j'ai trouvé plus à
constante parce que laisser un peu libre
cours à ses humeurs et ses contrariétés
donc forcément elle est un peu perdue
notamment lors de son annonce de son
départ
et puis le lendemain quand vous avez dit
qu'elle allait devenir chanteuse lâchez
vous et lâchait ce moment là maintenant
c'est
nouvelle génération et c'est
certainement les deux l'avenir de tpm
paix puisque agathe l'a dit il faut des
il faut des jeunes dans cette émission
elle dit qu'elle faisait partie des
jeunes donc c'est l'avenir donc comme
celles à venir je leur mets dix noms des
dix jeux mais une mais quatre agathe et
six agents lui que pour toi kelly battue
a su tirer son épingle du jeu de façon
très intelligente et très maligne et et
de façon très surprenante passivement
dans le dos de cyril il te vois un coup
sur deux est en fête a réussi à être
allés prochaine je m'attends rétroviseur
commence avec beaucoup de fraîcheur et
je trouve beaucoup d'intelligence et
shem t'amuser parti participe à la bonne
humeur de démission tout le monde ici tu
adores et et tafer moi je trouve ça fait
une très bonne année
si si tout le monde adore quand même il
faut continuer pas donner mon avis moi
j'aime bien quand tu es la petite
rebelle
moi j'aime bien quand tu tient tête aux
patrons ça me plaît beaucoup
donc bravo continue tour pour toi agathe
tu es une fille super étonnante agathe
parce qu'en fait on ne sait jamais sur
quel pied danser avec toi ab comme ça on
va prendre les termes de 6000 un jour tu
dans la dark à un jour tu es dans lara
sera dense et sa hâte à demain voilà en
revanche effectivement terme de boulot
battus à des avis tranchés donc tu
participes fortement au débat dans dans
l'émission et c'est absolument
nécessaire mais va falloir bosser ton
relationnel avec les camarades un gros
souci de relais mais sinon je te donne 6
pour toi et 7 pour quelque chose
moi j'ai pas voulu les désunir même pour
un conseil de classe donc je reviens là
toutes les deux 0 0 et qu'on connaît la
tête à toto
donc voilà je me lève on va voir on va
voir des blagues fin 18 0 pour des
raisons très simples 0 pour kelly parce
qu'elle bosse pas et ça se voit et 0
c'est bien de toi les héros pour agathe
pascale boss et ça se voit pas voilà un
peu les 2 cl ça je trouve très
complémentaires toutes les deux je
trouve charmante je trouve comme dirait
jean lui elles sont ni ton ça tu sais je
mets des bleus mais vous aviez pas ce
que je sais c'est pas tout non c'est
parce que je regarde le sol alors voilà
donc les épingles jean-michel fait même
débat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais je trouve qu'elles sont leurs
unités
kane qui n'est pas parole comme ça je
vous ça fait un bel ensemble joue parce
qu'elles sont devenues un peu garce
rebelles voilà je trouve ça fait un
ensemble qui est très marrant même si
elles s'entendent pas apple aurait loreo
comme ça de la dispute et je veux
clavier blanches et noires comme ça je
vous annonce à sa part exigé une
tendresse particulière ce camp en
unissant leurs forces elles pourraient
devenir un peu comme moi rien foot et
que ça se voit pas trop donc je vous
aime sur les notes dit la vérité qu'on
va vous mais non parce que je vais pas
les départager
bon bah trois mètres 5 et 5 mai 00 comme
son père sir alex est bon allez on y va
gérald alors qu'ils ont battu la
mascotte de l'émission tu es le bon sens
près de chez nous tu es toujours du
mérite agricole
c'est la part de rêve huawei laurent
maire c'est la peur je t'aime quand tu
danses jeu même quand tu arrives je
t'aime quand tu es fâché je t'aime
contre le fichier base ou encore qu'elle
est je t'aime dans toutes les situations
dans toutes les positions et je trouve
que tu est indispensable à cette toutes
les positions bah oui arrière dans notre
syrie ne vois là est en fait le truc que
tu est indispensable à cette émission et
donc c'est très agréable d'avoir à nos
côtés et donc moi je te mets un set et
les vidéos agathe alors magath a donc
battu à chalon vous êtes toujours alors
à gaudi mais vraiment que l'on concède
aussi à sec les professeurs et qu'on a
les lèvres difficile
on a des élèves qui arrivent avec le sac
us allaient commencer
née dans une classe de boulot chez nous
sommes dues au froid y'a pas gheit au
four 4 à notre place tahrir j'étais
dégoûté je voulais le kent
mon premier petit ami s'appelait gaëtan
haas pas vrai si bas vous savez je vais
vous dire c'est tintin c'est posez vous
les bonnes questions
alors sachez cyril coomans j'adore les
élèves difficiles
non c'est pas vrai donc agathe moi je te
trouve absolument brillante intrigante
attachante étrange singulière et donc ça
moi je trouve que c'est assez fascinant
voilà oui et en fait moi tu me fais
penser au poker et le poker c'est mon
jeu préféré dans le poker il faut
beaucoup de panache
beaucoup de flamboyance es-tu là et d'un
autre côté il faut mentir manipulé ben
le sait et c'est ça qui me plaît dans ce
jeu regardez le deuxième acte était là
et c'est ça qui m'étonne chez toi alors
il ya des soirs c'est plutôt bad beat
bit ça s'écrit b matin il ya dix ans
l'anglais il ya des soirs c'est à tour
la plus belle paire au poker c'est à
dire une perte 01 / a donc voila et
j'étais mis donc un 6/10 - agathe et
congrès pour t'aider
[Applaudissements]
alors là là en plus on va pas se mentir
à ses six essais revient sur les doses
maxime gagné au départ et vous les
pêcheurs kelly à belle île et ses
syndiqués j'ai l'impression que c'est
pas trop son délire donc si je m sur
agathe a précédé l'invasion qu'agathe
c'est pas trop mon délire s'est pas
loupé à contenir le jeu me mettre sur
mathieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
taxis et maintenant il signa va tout
donner sur christine kelly et les sur
vous il est sur le balan contrat c'est
que ça moi maintenant
oui bah oui non oui alors moi agathe
bon moi ça fait longtemps que je vous
connais toutes les deux donc je n'ai pas
souvent ensemble j'aime bien tes
remarques j'aime bien ton côté rebelle
j'aime bien leur présence oui moi j'aime
bien être belle et rebelle
c'est vrai moi c'est le seul moi je suis
moche héros moche et qu'est ce que
j'avais dit s'il faut un côté négatif
parfois je ne tombe pas assez souriante
voilà et kelly pour moi c'est la
définition même de la beauté
parce que la boîte ouais parce que la
beauté faut savoir la porte et s'est pas
uniquement l'extérieur si souvent tu es
comment tu portais tu supportes tu vois
ta beauté et je trouve que sur toi elle
est la porte très bien c'est à dire que
tu ne te la pètes pas tu me la joues pas
tu en joues panne ça tu joue vraiment au
bon niveau et c'est très rare chez une
femme extrêmement belle comme toi bats
bientôt 6 ml oui aussi je dédie à oui
mais les rebelles les ballons larves
enfin non les rebelles
moi je suis rebelles donc je ne sais
quoi les votes ma chérie alors la note
alors parce que ce sont deux femmes
parce que souvent les femmes sont
stigmatisés
[Musique]
du temps parce que souvent les femmes on
y adhère à ce message
10 non je déteste ça isabelle
morini-bosc apprend fera on fera mathieu
de la bretèche lundi la belgique et vous
tu chéris beau des spectacles comme elle
a plein de tout on voit pas quel point
le visage et est magnifique sur la foi
falbala faille de nouer et belle des
champs c'est la balade dans le fromage
alors j'espère bien qu'elle va faire ce
rappel saint-alfred un milieu souvent à
quoi il sert eh ben elle sert à être là
et c'est déjà énorme parce
qu'effectivement et spontanée bonne
qualité
pour ce qui est des à lui et des avis
souvent pertinent quand elle sent pas
avec un homme paniqué et donc moi je la
trouve absolument formidable et je lui
mets moi neuf et demi pour passer son
année à rien [ __ ]
agacé catalan ouais bah oui bah vous
l'avez plus désolé
[Applaudissements]
on y va alors agathe est étonnant
pertinentes à pertinentes alors à part
le jour où tu as dis du mal d'un
programme que tu avais pas vu d'ailleurs
tu as eu l'honnêteté de le dire tu sais
étayer les airs et sont intéressants
mais on peut dire que tu intrigue à tous
les sens du terme je pense qu'on a toute
l'année prochaine pour se découvrir et
je te mets ont leur cinquième quand même
très vite
kelly tu parles passait jamais tu parle
davantage agathe tu parles trop
j'aimerais que tu te fais tout pour ça
parce que j'adore d'analogique en
plateau c'est juste la belle et tais toi
je te mets à 3 parce que je t'en veux
et toi parce qu'en début d'année était
très sympathique tu jouais tuerie n'est
qu'après tu t'es pris au sérieux je te
mets 5 parce que je pense que c'est
tombé en kelly moi évidemment je suis
totalement séduit depuis le début que je
vais rester exceptionnelles elle est
très important dans l'émission parce
qu'elle apporte non seulement la beauté
la grâce mais en plus ce côté généreux
solaire sympathique agréable bonne
copine tu es magnifique il amoureux
ensuite agathe à gâteau si tu es très
belle dans un autre style très très
belle et agréable brillante etc
et je crains que au cours de la veille à
une petite race ramé en toi
personnellement rien vu qui s'est
reportée sur nous aussi un peu et donc
voila mais je vais vous dire à toutes
les deux parce que c'est très agréable
de vous voir toutes les deux tous les
jours merci au case ih
bref finalement je me sens un peu comme
charlie avec les bons de damian la brune
et la blonde
j'aime les deux on a eu un différend
avec agathe mais elle a fait preuve
d'une vraie générosité avec un tweet
voilà pour mes enfants c'est mon petit
poussin adoré c'est bien sûr la belle
kelly je pourrais pas vous départager
qui est dit a dénoncé trois disques dans
l'année donc trois disques bas 1,3 et 3
ça fait 3 voilà vingt trois alors là là
là toi on t'attend parce que les gens tu
attends là dessus j'aimerais ouais je
rappelle à ceux qui l'on doit
il a voulu pécho kelly kelly une amie ce
qu'on appelle dans le milieu
ah bon un rapport une porte mais pas une
porte cdh a pris la tête au port de fort
boyard blindés dans la le guellec la
clepsydre ici après il a voulu pécho te1
garde ce n'est pas du tout en plus ce
sujet sur tout le monde a gagné
si tu te mords toi-même de mode il a
voulu ensuite pécho agathe magath sait
plus ce qu'on appelle dans le milieu
une frêle zone de ouf c'est à dire il ya
voilà il ya un délire là voilà on a
envie de m voilà on a envie de pécho la
personne c'est-à-dire de l'embrasser au
galop sage et la faire je lui dis
attention tout gardons bien sûr on met
le triangle de sécurité serait sa 59e
c'est ça je rappelle de très égale
sécurité un trait donc c'est ce qui
s'est passé on s'écoute
alors c'est vrai que vous êtes
incomparable différentes complémentaires
vais commencer par kelly kelly est un
peu notre petit bonbon notre bulle d'air
un trio de soleil orient petit point
négatif quand même sûr que tu as un
bandana ou même un peu chaud deuxième
chose c'est négatif tu as abandonné un
peu rapidement le côté des jets
il ya un potentiel de dengue a balancé
des sons à rendre les messieurs encore
meilleur de trois fois samba mais cinq
derrière c'est compliqué ça me courant
intervenir on sent un peu excentré du
plateau non mais très bon quand tu es
très loin
[Applaudissements]
ouais j'aurais une question à se poser
quant à fait d'accord savoir chat très
important point positif on voit la chine
est positif sensible par kelly et
surtout tu prends de plus en plus
confiance en toi
ouais lorsque cyril te donne la parole
sur des sujets précis ou à voir elle
avait tranché pour pour agathe agathe la
saison a été mouvementée pour toi tu ne
laisse pas indifférente en fait c'est un
peu là la grande tornade de bourine sexe
parfois sur le plateau tu es toujours
déterminée ou les interventions et tu as
les mots justes pour exprimer pour
négatif tu as une belle assurance qui
peut passer pour de l'arrogance au goût
un peu de prétention
par moment alors que non pas du tout
c'est vrai je suis hyper cool et positif
tué brillante et tu rayonne dans tes
interventions il avait arrêté du préfet
si tu devais partir en vacances avec
l'une des lunes celle sur le web et j'ai
eu une seule ce fut partir avec kelly ou
agathe avec et les pénalités ni jean
michel quévit que christine kelly bas
c'est normal sur tb assez vague mais ces
vacances ou s'est couché vacances mais
après peut se passer quand même
kelly kelly kelly kelly bravo tu te
tapes tout le monde à bord a alors servi
par dont trois mois avec vous moi moi
moi je vais vous dire la vérité
[Rires]
c'est oublié
[Musique]
écoutez ce comme social entre mon père
et ma mère je ne choisis pas je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
après quoi c'est le moment des pauses et
soisy une
c'est la vision correcte
[Applaudissements]
comme une partie ramènera la panoz elle
était rouge par avec toi mais on
voudrait aller la radiation pour faire
la balance comme les majorités a visité
les chefs alain balland choisi agatha